one this is Kevin from the chess website
calm today we're going to be going over
the two bishop in game for white and how
to checkmate the King if you haven't
stayed this before this would be a very
good opportunity to learn different
techniques and even more so than just
checkmate the King just learn how the
bishops can work together well when
attacking you can use this if there are
more pieces on the board but if you just
have two bishops we're going to go ahead
and get into it and show you how to go
about it so first thing you want to do
now keep in mind as we go over this
video there are many many different ways
to checkmate the King and no I'm
actually not going to be showing you the
fastest way I'm going to show you the
easiest way so if you can figure out how
to do it a faster way and you want to do
that that's fine but I'm going to go
over what I think is the easiest way so
starts out I like to centralize my King
first and then get the bishops nearby
next to each other and then I basically
just like to push the King back push the
King back in checkmate so we'll see how
that looks here white moves first
White's just going to move up here and
black King is going to move as well b5
really doesn't matter where he moves and
I'm going to go ahead and centralize my
King here at d4 and blacks king is going
to go ahead and
move back and I'm going to go ahead and
centralize my first bishop again this is
the key concept centralizing your
bishops activating your king nearby and
then pushing the King back so blacks can
go ahead and move and I'm going to go
ahead and activate this bishop here as
you can see this bishop this white
bishop is taking away this long diagonal
on the a2h file and so the black king is
limited now to these green squares that
I have highlighted so he's going to have
to go ahead and go that route so you can
already see the limited space the black
King has so he's going to go ahead and
move and we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go ahead and move our
white bishop here and see where the
black King goes the black King could
come to f6 and then we could go ahead
and drop our bishop back still limiting
more moves that the black King can do
but black King is going to go ahead and
move to f7 and we're going to go ahead
and stick with what we've been doing and
that's moving the bishops neck to each
other so limiting more squares and as
you'll see key concept when these two
bishops are next to each other the
entire rank right above it the King
cannot come down so the sixth rank here
the King cannot pass and so we are
really taking away squares that the King
can go to and we have not moved very
much so we're going to go ahead and can
you continue black King has to move to
one of those squares and he moves and
now we really don't have any good moves
for the bishop so we're going to go
ahead and start to activate our King a
little bit more and black King has to
retreat and we're going to go ahead and
bring our King to a better position
and black king is forced to move back
this long diagonal and he couldn't come
here because of our King and so now
we're going to do our first check we're
going to go ahead and move our white
bishop here he can't come back - ff8 or
he can move to d8 those are his two
moves if he does decide to go d8 we'll
take a look at that or if he moves to f8
it'll be more the same we will move our
bishop here and he'll be confined to
even less space but if he does decide to
move to d8 then we are going to simply
do the same move as if we would gone to
g8 we're going to go ahead and move our
bishop to f6 and this limits the black
King to one space he can only move to
this c8 square our bishops have cut off
these moves and again he can't move this
rank here because of our King so black
king is have to move to c8 square and
now we're going to go ahead and move our
King we're going to go and activate him
use him a little bit more and again
since we have this bishop on this
diagonal this the King is again limited
to only one space so black king is going
to move there and we are going to
continue our activation of our King now
black king can move either place A or C
either way he's going to have the same
fate so pretty much the same moves are
going to happen if he moves to a eight
then we're going to a slow move we're
not going to put them in check yet but
we're going to go ahead and put our
Bishop here on at five limiting to this
b8 squared
getting ready for a to move checkmate so
he black is forced to this b8 square and
now we can pretty much use both of our
bishops first move is going to be this e
2 e 5 square
forcing him back to the eighth square
now notice if we didn't put our our
light square bishop here earlier then
the black king could retreat back to
this c8 square but since he was nicely
placed here the black king is forced to
retreat to this square and then the
light square bishop is going to come
down and check made him so that's
obviously if he goes to the left to the
d8 square we're going to go ahead and
take a look if black decides to move to
the f8 square and again like I said
before we're going to go ahead and
continue what we've been doing we're
going to bring up our bishop to the f6
square and block off the King's mobility
black King now has two moves our two
spaces he can move to only one he can
move two but two available squares and
so he's going to be forced to go to the
g8 square and from here we're going to
go ahead and like we've always done
we're going to activate our King get
them alongside the bishop as you can
recall from the very early moves we
actually have this same setup and we've
actually just moved this set up down the
board getting the King closer and closer
to checkmate so King only has one move
because of the bishops he's going to
have to go back to f8 and when he moves
back to f8 now we can start we have a
great position we can go ahead and start
getting our bishops in range and you can
go ahead and just conceptually think
about what we're doing here we're going
to go ahead and move this Bishop back we
eventually want them to checkmate it
much like we did all along the a8 square
and this little subtle move the black
King still only has one place you can go
and that's the g8 square so that's very
important
and so he's going to move there and our
King is going to go ahead and take the
place of that Bishop again we don't want
this king to be able to move on the
seventh rank so we want to go ahead and
take his place
Bishop is taking off this h7 square and
the King is taking the rest of these
black can choose to go either f8 or h8
doesn't matter the same fate will be
brought upon him we'll go ahead and look
at f8 here and now we're going to go
ahead and bring this Bishop into a
better position go ahead and check the
King the black King has to move to the
g8 Square and say move he'll to gone to
h8 we would still bring this Bishop here
and he would just go from H a to g8 same
fate like I said before black King's
going to go ahead and move to g8 and now
we're going to go ahead and get our
other LightSquared Bishop into the
actions who's just going to drop back
one f5 and the black king is forced to
go to H a and we are going to go ahead
and like we did with the dark square
Bishop we're going to go ahead and take
the place of our light squared bishop
with our King here so again he cannot
move along this seventh rank and the
black king is forced to move along the
8th ranked on the g8 Square has only
moved so he's going to move to the g8
Square and then much like we had on the
other side it's a very easy win from
here White's going to go ahead and move
his light square bishop check black is
forced into the corner and white can go
ahead and come down with his dark square
bishop and checkmate the King so
hopefully you all enjoy this video like
I said before there are very very many
ways to check make the the King with two
bishops I feel like this is the easiest
if you do want some practice you can
actually check out my website I have a
few variations where you can go and
actually practice playing against
computer with two bishops and that
website is
practice there so hope you guys enjoyed
definitely subscribe so you know when
new videos are coming out a lot more
should be posted shortly and have a good
one